foreign
Tom how can we help
hey guys I have a rental question okay I
got a new landlord in July
he said he was going to get a management
company to come and take care of
everything
uh he gave me his name I didn't sign
anything no new lease or anything uh and
then I never saw him again so I'm
sitting on six months rent haven't heard
from anybody just wondering what to do
whoa
okay for six months
you've not seen or heard you've not
gotten a bill nothing is this person
alive
that's kind of what either he's in jail
or he's
dead is this a house is there are you
renting a house
a dude he bought two duplexes right next
to each other and he hasn't picked up
rent from anybody okay so so this isn't
just you you have other people that are
in the duplexes with you with you and
nobody's heard anything
yeah and we did the math it's over 20k
in rent that he's hasn't picked up does
he own the did he own these duplexes
outright or was he in debt for him
oh I'm not sure
well
this is very I would honestly go to
police and do a welfare check on this on
this person yeah yeah because my in-laws
are worried he's trying to pull some
kind of scam but I
I know it's a weird scam to pull when
there's no money coming out of your
account yeah you're like you're not
you're not you're not legally liable for
anything you haven't even signed a lease
agreement
and that's the other thing he said our
rent was going to go up another 400 but
we didn't sign anything so my neighbor
is still
budgeting the old rent and not the new
rent because he doesn't sign anything do
you think I should uh go off of what he
said the increase
oh first of all you you don't point it
it's all yeah there's there's nothing
for you to do other than I guess you
could like George said file a missing
person uh or do a little research and
find out where this guy is because what
the only thing I'm concerned about I
honestly Tom you kind of I'm processing
this one if I was in your shoes
first of all I wouldn't be paying
anybody anything I haven't gotten a bill
we haven't heard from the guy definitely
save on to the money yeah you don't want
to spend that money but I'm not spending
it but I'm also making plans to go
somewhere else in case this thing goes
you know wacky you know
he's either going to show up at some
point and ask for the money or
something's really wrong and you're not
going to be able to squat there forever
right so I'd save the money and have a
backup well that's what we're doing I
know but you're technically not doing
anything wrong because the owner is not
existing here's the other thing I would
do I would absolutely stay there but I
would have a plan that I could get out
of there in 36 48 hours if I had to
okay yeah is there any other uh
Association tied to the the building
is there anyone else you get in touch
with
we maintenance anyone
well that's the weird thing is
somebody's still paying the water bill
you know water still works all right so
call the water department like just do a
little bit of pan we need to get in
touch with them yeah I I I would do this
is a very uh simple investigation thing
here where you can call the utilities
and start nosing around and figure out
what's going on I'd be preparing to
leave something doesn't add up it's
weird spooky situation spooky and
Spokane George
that's what's going on there leave it to
Ken Coleman with the alliteration I love
it I'm always here for you George